first of all I want to underline the
outstanding unity of all the 27 leaders
on the guidelines for our negotiations
with the UK we now have unanimous
support from all the 27 member states
and the EU institutions giving us a
strong political mandate for these
negotiations before negotiating our
future relations of the UK we must first
achieve sufficient progress on citizens
rights finances and the border issue in
Ireland it will be for the EU leaders to
assess and decide if sufficient progress
has been made and this will be a
unanimous decision of all the 27 head
let me now focus on our priority number
one namely citizens we are talking about
four and a half million people Europeans
residing in the UK and Britons living on
the continent
we need real guarantees for our people
to live work and study in the UK and the
same goes for the Brits
we need a serious British response I
want to assure you that as soon as the
UK offers real guarantees for our
citizens we will find a solution rapidly